hi everyone it's Jerry I'm going to hop
into this
hourly super Blitz Arena
57 minute event
of 3-0 a couple IMS in here
they logged in they're logged in
all right let's see who we get in round
one
okay morphe chests
let's go into
Sicilian land
okay
go with A4
retain some flexibility with my d-pawn
for the moment
I guess that's
short-lived
I don't think I'm gonna play D4
I'm shooting for a quick E5 I want to
break up this group
retaking with the a pawn if the capture
is okay
trying to work on this night
okay
play D3
Bishop F4
I like the open file
am I asking for trouble if I play here
um
Bishop F4 Bishop D3
here
and see how it should be okay
let's start with this
we have mass exchanges I'm guessing
that's what I'm signing up for at least
with Bishop F4 if Bishop D6 we're
probably going to have all of these
exchanged I'll end up with The Rook on
this Square
pressure on the pawn I like the end game
with two Rooks and the Knight
a piece
chopping away
and here we are
expecting the queen Exchange
maybe Rook Rook after C8 is a another
move
in the ending I'll probably go be going
with this one okay I didn't expect that
to get into giving up this Square so now
have this idea
Knight B6 is possible okay it seems like
I'm gonna be winning a pawn
this Knight's under control the knights
are offset
it's a superior structure
for white
okay so they're probably going for I
mean I don't have to take right now but
I don't see why not
oh I didn't see that one coming
what's the story exactly though
okay let's
let's actually go one step
yeah
okay
um do I keep sneaking over I guess
I don't want to jump in here too soon
because the knights Knight's gonna hop
here
and now this this crossed my mind these
moves
if I move this Knight I'm a little
concerned about this Knight getting to
maybe that square okay so let's let's
control these
okay
I feel like I could break this down a
little bit more now
let's go with the B4
maybe I could even think about moving my
knight and playing B5 to have a
connected past Pawn
if black tries to maintain the tension
okay so even right here
think this is desirable because now this
frees up my Rooks to go elsewhere
and where should elsewhere be let's
start with
going here
just generating a threat
and
let's go with this one nice little Pawn
chain
and
let's regroup a little bit we have to
play some defense
rookie three I'm going to look to next
open up a file
on the king side
I'm not behind on the clock
so let's start with the h-pone
not concerned about my Rook getting
trapped
there's no black Pond that can control
both of these squares
okay
good try
okay let's go here
just want an open file to get at this
point
is shut down
so just looking for one key Pawn break I
want to stay out of this
one little trick
okay
so I have a pawn break here
maybe I don't even need a palm brick
let's get this one in though
I could have played this one actually
okay
could play it now
or
let's just go here
got that
Safety First
I guess we'll grab another poem
I'll see why not
let's go for this idea
get this file
this is the new seventh rank
the check checkmate that would be
actually
it was not the cleanest approach what
I'm doing here
will be enough though
it was a bit sloppy there at the end
okay
round one is in the books
is in first
six and a five
I won't be doing any berserking
all right
I am in round two
okay
Indian
it's Castle
and it's playing the center
all right
as soon as the white is kind of saying
I'm gonna feed keto some pressure on C4
is usually a good idea
oh this was probably a little sloppy
allowing Queen there okay could undo it
get my Bishop out of this problem
Queen B3 would x-ray two unprotected
pieces
so now I'm in a spot to meet Queen B3
with Queen to B6 let's go let's go here
Knight D6 it's tactically vulnerable
or excuse me Knight D7 instead of Queen
to E7
my Bishop would be hanging
I got take here no time for the
in-betweener
they hit me with an in-betweener
I'm cool with this move
uh let's go with this one meeting Queen
B3 with
Queen before that was my idea so let's
play on this side
see if the H Pawn scares them at all
not too concerned about this night
should I be
um
let's just go here for a minute
Queen E7
there's there's Pressure Queen B3 okay
yeah that's making me wonder
if I should have played
maybe H4 but all right
let's go here
remove an important Defender
my king is or my knight is closer to my
king okay
don't really have much Choice getting
forked
so Rook specific ending
how could two pieces pile up on this I'm
not saying how
so
let's go here
watch out for the E4 break there aren't
many breaks left in the position okay
they are going with this
okay yeah and this row could even slide
over here I think I need to take
and it feels like it's very trash
I guess I'll take once
it feels very Josh I think all these are
going to be exchanged
Queen side Pawns
we'll see maybe a queen exchange all
right that one
so this here there
I'm worse if anything
yeah
I have to just try for a draw
I don't think I have anything better
uh yeah I have that one okay
babysit for a little bit
try and be a little irritating to the
king
don't want him getting activated that's
okay so now I think they have to hide
okay because now I get this maneuver and
my Rook is all of a sudden that
aggressor and I win the b-pone
so I'm the one who's now playing for a
win
interesting decision here okay I think I
need this guy still around as shelter
okay
there's these stalemate tricks
okay yeah there's these stalemate tricks
yikes
all right
which Pond do I take first I guess this
one
it's not a it's Checkmate if they go
there okay
oh no actually it's a it's a fairly
simple win
yeah I just pushed this guy all the way
here and just keep running with this guy
forgetting about this so the King has to
hide now
I could just go here
if he ever comes out he gets hit with a
check no stalemates
I just zigzag
oh I missed that idea
guess it's a little bit more complicated
yeah still he can't he can't sneak out
so easily
yeah
a couple to a couple Tempe ahead
oh
Mouse slipped there or something
like enough gas in the tank that was
sloppy oh
they need to be a little bit more
careful with the f-pawn I think as soon
as they played F4 I started to
get excited there they need I think they
need to hide with their King
King H3
and then it was I don't think we could
either side can make progress
as the one idea really turn the tables
going from
passive a rook going from a passive to
an active state
all right
God before
wow this is really flying by some long
games
okay let's try B3
okay
let's go with 92 and I'm gonna shoot for
F4
that's why I'm going to the atypical
square is this Pawn not up for grabs I
think it is there's no
fancy counters with a check or anything
or some coordination with the bishop
it's
it's a big pawn and a big Rook
at the end of the day
okay they resigned
they missed the
Queen side fiend Keto
all right this is the number two guy
all right let's hit D4 head-on
and let's hop in see how they react
preserve the bishop
okay I like my position
yeah
what do I like about it I like that I
have a healthier structure
not healthier just slightly Superior
fourth rank versus third rank C Pawn
nothing
special
but uh it's comfortable equal at least
here for black
all right let's take a timeout to flick
in the flight Square now this Knight G5
I'd have to create two holes
it's G6
okay
let me go here to stop the idea of
playing E4
let's build my Center
maybe continue to build it
they seem like they're in the the
trading mood
I'm cool with that
I have an open file
okay what's a good approach in this Rook
ending
if this I'll be kicked right away
not accepting a draw for
let's go here
or no let's improve the king I'm not
sure where the Rooks belong
in fact let's stop this break
let me just continue to grab space on
the
King's side
yeah let's do that I'm not sure how to
arrange these pawns really
let's go here
um no let's go here in case this I have
that and then I'm covering all those
fourth rank squares
this is a move okay they're shooting for
this one maybe maybe I go here now
watching out for the pawn breaks I think
I think I want one Rook off now
making is going to feel a little bit
more comfortable
approaching the center
I have space okay
so how do we want to approach this
I want to go faster
okay
let's take here we're really down on the
clock
let's get a little more space
Rick wants to be somewhere else
probably shouldn't have allowed that
break
now it feels like a draw
I'm allowing that Rook activity
okay I have some activity though all my
pawns are isolated though
but my Rook is wild
oh
didn't see that one
they could create the outside passer
okay
they're under the defensive though
King up I have this just trying to
create a connection point where my Roca
camp out here
should have maybe flicked that one in
whoa that was a big miss that wasn't a
mouse slip either because
why would they want to go here
forgetting my Rook was there
kind of bizarre
okay they're putting the pressure on me
the clock
uh I think there was still chances to
make some
uh to make life difficult for my
opponent in that in that ending
my king felt a little more comfortable
than theirs
all right
let's see
a chop on C4 or not
all right
I can't go to G5
let's back off now
I like my position
exchange my bad Bishop
again the case of fourth rank versus
third ranked C Pawn
worthwhile to jump in and play F4
now
let's just keep it as is
I want to change the structure
I'm hoping they take here before my
Bishop moves
seems like a healthy move
so they're going for E5 break
um
castle and I'm going to take on an
isolated Pawn
I want to control this guy
I like that I get this Tempo in
Pawn is pinned so this would be a nice
move to see
foreign
let's go here right now because they're
probably trying to offset my Bishop
okay I don't mind that one
um
actually maybe I do mind that
okay let's go with this
yeah
you need to take some care over this
Pawn
let's take with this
stay defending here
two Rooks okay no no two Rooks situation
for the queen
to improve the king
Knight F6 Queen E5
now let's try this
be taking with the pawn okay
oh that isn't that isn't a blender
okay
I really don't want to trade but I think
I have to
yeah I need to hurry over here
I'm just realizing my Rook is defended
so these moves are not there
what is it with these rook and pawn
endings
we got another one here
not sure exactly where my Rook is going
I guess I wanted to stop rookie H5
these moves are irritating
I think my king is there in time to
weather the storm
let's actually start with this
A5 I'm expecting yeah
if I played here before B4 I get hit
with C5
not sure how to assess this
King F5 sneaking in it's sort of scary
probably flick this one in if King F5
feels like it would be a draw if the
Rooks are exchanged okay they're giving
me a Target
maybe let's just give this
check first
have to make a decision okay
I feel like I'm a little better now
slightly improved uh
with the king or The Rook position
and do I chop I think I chop
and put this Rook on a the most active
Square
okay
how do I make progress
I don't know that this is progress
and I try to go after this Pawn
there is some distance between these two
base points
G5 and C6
should I even be trying to
um The Wind by position with the clock
situation
The Rook is tied down King doesn't have
many options there is a bit of a wall
formed
again all isolated pawns for me
my king could approach
well let's just do this for a quick test
I think they should flick in the check
yeah
that's in I'm not sure what to do move
rookie or maybe there
okay
let's give this check mate
oh what am I doing this is one king and
pawn ending
okay
wow
a lot of these are coming right down to
the ending
how many
there's like three of them
yeah let's put it three of the games are
uh
I'm just kidding I just I'm getting
berserked in this one three of the five
games are rook and pawn endings
okay let's take some care over D5 that's
a hole I'm guessing they're going for
Queen side castles so
all right so it's clamped down in the G3
idea
and
let's go here I don't know if I want to
play with B5
let's go with this why why don't I want
to play with B5 it's because I'm a
little concerned about
like some night in here a knight
connecting on this Square
I'm concerned about the the whole
created
on C6 when I play B5
I was just ready to run into a fork
okay
this Knight is actually
irritating
and let's go here so that
this is not yet a move
can't take with the queen because of
Rook takes
put pressure here maybe maybe now I'm
thinking about going here
or
or what
maybe I just go here
let's go one step
okay gotta go
I have to challenge that Queen
another ending
Rook up and over
and I'm gonna have the more active Rook
okay they're on the defensive
don't think my rook's getting trapped
okay
um let's go not sure what I'm supposed
to do here
let's try this one
my king could Step Up
slight Improvement
let's see if they
Exchange
I could go for maybe a break there okay
another rook and pawn ending
all right
yeah I want to be in a spot to challenge
the more active Rook
cut off the king
improve my own King
actually I could start to pry at these
pawns a little bit
let's go this direction
I got this covered
the king in the center
this Rook is tied down yeah they're not
sure what to do I'm not sure what to
suggest for them
this is a
pretty clean plan let's go here
go here if the Rook moves okay
um
let's try this
got a passer now this one restricts
these two
a check another check
The Rook really can't move so easily
got the mate
all right
four out of the six games
rook and fun ending holy cow
only 27 minutes left
time flies by
with these super super Blitz arenas
349 in there
oh this is the top dog a berserk okay
let's let's go with the berserk back
so a bullet game flicked into the Super
Blitz Arena
uh let's wait for them to
address the pin before going here
I guess I'll take now
I think
okay
fancy
if I play here
is that going to be complicated for you
my calculations are correct
got two problems after Knight takes C6
there and here
okay oh I'm not threatening this what am
I doing
okay
let's go here
oh I just blundered
this Knight takes here I have this maybe
yeah could I
could I
another in-betweener
can't take I can't take with this Rook
another rook and pond ending
okay they're not going for that
I guess let's just scare this queen into
taking my Bishop
they're not taking the bishop why not
okay now they're taking for compound
ending
my Pawn cannot be cut
ideal spot for The Rook
get behind instead of pushing
I want to make sure I establish this
position first
oh I should have stepped there
that was bad
we're just gonna try to get all rook and
pawn endings
that's all that's the big plan
wow I don't know if I've ever had this
many
games like this what is that losing
track five out of the seven I've played
seven games
I think five of them are broken Pawn all
right I'm one point back
Charlie let's go with E4
Carlos
Carlos 99 is in first
all right I don't mind if I go on
castled
let's get some space it's extra
appealing now that it hit with tempo
let's maintain
the pawn structure
uh let's go with this baby move
yeah I wanna
Force the hand of the the C Pawn so now
we're in a maneuvering situation
let's cut out a quick G5 expansion
I want this guy here it takes a while
but
or does it no it doesn't I was thinking
I have to Pivot on this Square I was
ready to blunder my Bishop as well
okay
let's start with this one or
yeah let's start with this
yeah they're going for A5
hmm
I was thinking I have to
take okay let's go with
let's go with the
let's go with the pawn I don't want to
give this guy
like I don't want to exchange queens and
I don't want to be in a position where
this is available
um
I don't know
oh they're they're they're lining up a
trick there let's get castle to get off
of this diagonal really down on the
clock
I try to make progress here oh they're
going for a sacrifice
okay
yeah you got a point
my knight is
kind of stupid
see if we can get some trades I won't I
don't mind if
they capture here because then maybe my
queen could do something on the dark
squares
I don't know
going for this third Pawn I guess
let's try and be active
as possible with the queen
okay
put pressure on the pond and this is
more about a this is more of a defensive
move
I don't even know how I'm supposed to
activate my pieces
um there maybe my night
no no wonderful discoveries
for uh
for the bishop just yet
hmm
pressure here
okay
like could I get a knight to one of
these squares somehow
I'll put this maneuver
you pressure on something
I feel like I'm going to be needing to
sacrifice peace soon
to stop one of these guys
if they ever get moving
if my king was more active towards the
queen side I could be more comfortable
exchanging queens and putting the king
here
but I'm not there just yet
I don't know
maybe maybe I could do something here
I feel like I might want to sacrifice if
they push this guy
I was expecting them to play this for
for a bit
just trying to be as irritating as
possible
I'm not seeing any possible sacrifices
with uh my Bishop
I think I should be able to track this
Pawn down I like my Queen's a nice block
hater my Knight's doing a good job
defending D4 they're down on time
okay
let's maybe go for this maneuver Bishop
C2
hmm
oh they moved
the king
oh dark squares
should be something good
oh it's hanging it's running mate
got the Rook coming over
oh my Bishop was on that
no stalemates get out of here Bishop
oh man
that was not easy
tough to make progress there it's an
interesting sacrifice
interesting
um
yeah whenever there's that that pawn
that is in your house like that what
they have they had a Pawn on C4
so the sacrifices that eliminate Pawns
and help that
Pawn become mobile
am I
it's tough
they were connected
and passed
not easy
okay I'll be moving with my queen soon
out of Harm's Way
oh that Moon
a knight's in a pin
all right I don't mind if this is played
and they try and damage my Pawns
okay Now's the Time to get out of Harm's
Way
definitely do not want to allow the
Knight to track down my dark Square
Bishop
this may be a move at some point taking
advantage of an unprotected Queen but
not now
she's defended
is there a way to get at The Rook
not really saying it
security for
and
I guess here I'm I'm prepared to
dive into this square at some point
or
yeah
let's prep B4
you have some space okay so my idea is
this
and then to have this file
but oh that dropped when I didn't want
it to drop but
that's my mouse acting up
okay
is this too slow of an idea
you're here and then this I want to get
off of this diagonal
okay
it's a bit weakening to do this but
I want to stop a G4 advance for
at least a move
okay let's go here
I was thinking about this in here that
drops H3
not so fast
so everything is with this setup is
pointing at the night jump
and I probably should go ahead for that
or do I play this no
probably just jump in this isn't even a
threat because I'm on that one
definitely taking towards the center
okay
ducking The Night Exchange
let's see if they're scared
this move
that's the perfect that's the kind of
reasoning you should always use let's
just see if they're scared
foreign
okay
let's go here
and work on this Square
oh they're taking this Knight is
tremendous
has a huge grip on
these these two Pawn advances so
so what let's go here
maybe put all my energy on D6
and then maybe this and then that
would not find a queen Exchange
let's stop the break
if the H file opens up this king is not
going to feel comfortable okay so much
for that it's shut down on the king side
and let's hop in
and I'm gonna go here just to tuck my
king away a little bit
and nearby this I'm ready to
go ahead and smash away
and it seems like I'll probably end up
winning a queen with my Rooks it's like
everything is on the second rank first
or second rank so
got Forks
seventh and eighth rank Brooks with this
Knight around and my Bishop is a good
Guardian for my king
okay that I did not expect
okay this bishop is under control by my
now let's let's start with the capture
okay
um
to be a bit careful
my back rank now
okay this was not the cleanest approach
I shouldn't have captured here I should
have went with my my instinct here Rook
C8
might be asking for trouble okay
whoa
where's my time
don't hurt me
oh my goodness barely won that
what an ugly ending
yuck
I had Rooks in the end oh
man I shouldn't have captured on C5 I
was just commenting that
I need my Bishop around to secure my
king
so with the capture on C5
yeah
my Bishop was no longer going to be
around
as Mr Defender all right so what do we
what do we have here an exchange or not
exchange we have a French defense
okay Advanced French
okay
I guess here
I don't know how to play this
D4
[Music]
all right
let's try and get rid of this Knight
he's a great defender a great piece
attacker and Defender
hmm
let's go for this actually changed my
mind
allowing me to take that dark Square
Bishop
I don't know that I even want it
let's just go here I like my knight on
F5
okay
can't win a pawn because I'm taking here
and then recapturing
oh that's so that's a very uh
interesting follow-up
so I should probably take like this and
then
go here
oh I did not expect that one
all right
um
let's not get into time pressure here
and we'll go here I guess
I wanna I wanna kick this Knight away oh
I could push here
I wanted I wanted this and then
Bishop there okay so now I should be
taking
and then taking here this Knight's a bit
clumsy
this night however
not clumsy
let's scare this guy
definitely do not want to take
that night
all right I could have I could have
considered that
with Bishop B5 as the follow-up
two Bishops versus two knights
I want to try and Target
pounds on dark because
what else am I supposed to do
hmm
let's go here to stop Rook B3
for a minute
this also crossed my mind okay night
there
um we're compound ending
no don't want it
are they defending this
wow
Knight has to go here
making progress now
wow oh they have that attack
let's come all the way back
my time oh man
I don't even know what that's doing
I should have challenged this truck much
sooner
time time time
I don't know what I'm supposed to do
here
oh I wanted that
I don't know if I should have gone like
this I'm not gonna sneak into C6
I can't move
Rook gets trapped oh oh I should have
played here what am I doing
hopefully they don't play Rook A8
gotta go
wow
chalk it up
he's got some ugly games here at the end
oh man all right let's see if we could
hang on to second first is
not happening
this game may not even finish for the
tournament
okay
let's try E4
final one
and
let's go Bishop C4
I made this error recently
the fork trick is not there when the
Bishop's on C4
in a Blitz game
all right overtaking the center
and let's keep going this
this
kind of tricky to untangle now
I feel like I could get this Pawn
whenever I want so
I'd prefer to take it with a different
piece like a bishop
instead of the queen like I'm expecting
a queen to be kicked around okay so we
could maybe still
the D6 May return
this Knight could also get caught so
Knight A5 Bishop there and now this is a
threat I don't know how you saved the
Knight
this is probably nearby two Greek gift
stuff
okay and if I
plant this guy here
what's the story
follow-up B4
and this guy is officially cooked
oh I'm in third
to try and get this one in they could
always stall
minute 39
silver or bronze
see
okay
where am I vulnerable
this night's unprotected with B4 but
yeah
okay
I was thinking this first but let's do
this right now
in my knight
maintaining a piece on this Square clogs
up the entire Queen side
yeah so now there's two
two problems too many
maybe even before I take the Knight I
swipe this guy just so I don't have to
worry about the Knight being irritating
on
F4
but even so there's nothing there this
is a
good defense
um
okay I'll take
it's not gonna count
Ken I feel like I don't even want to
take that night
all right I guess I'll take them now
the queen in the center
I'm not concerned about these
sacrifices there's nothing to
follow up with okay my knight is hit
it's also a coordinated pressure
and F3 but
upon here connect Knights
you go here
offer a queen Exchange
if it's declined I get in D6
clogging up the queen side and by this
point when The Rook if B6
maybe smothered made ideas
these guys are too good
one's an extra
okay
I guess here
it's not easy to create a flight Square
either because of this Knight
okay
oh that's what they were doing
okay going for this
I should have played this instead of the
um
The Rook move to E1 is there a flashy
way to finish
seems like a good way
clean here
yeah
okay not the cleanest games around
in the end
third with 37.
and we didn't get a pairing
both ended up
on a hundred percent
all right let me throw a good games all
it's been a while since I
hopped in one of these while recording
locally
all right good games all and yeah Feel
Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe take a
thing or two away probably something
related to rook and pawn endings
anyhow that's all for now take care bye
foreign